if the world was getting ripped apart by
Savage monsters from underground what
would you do horrifying alien creatures
have begun rising from the deepest parts
of the Earth's core and will stop at
nothing to kill and sacrifice you and
your friends I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the monsters in gamra rebirth
these kids have no idea that they will
be hunted down and sacrificed by
monsters and humans Boo Here spends time
with his friends before moving away
after summer vacation living in a
military town they head to their secret
Clubhouse and talk about buying a radio
so they can all stay in touch when he
leaves finally saving enough pocket
money they head to the store to buy it
but run into the school bully this
American kid named Brody says his dad is
the general at the local military base
and he makes fun of Boo's friends and
their country him and his gang tried to
steal all of their money and kick their
asses later boo complains to them that
they need to get their money back so
they can buy their radio because staying
friends forever is really the most
important thing they can do right now
convincing the others they plan to
attack them later that night for Revenge
not realizing that horrifying monsters
will attack this city and the world in
just a few hours later boo and his
friends track down the school bullies in
town not hearing the city's evacuation
Sirens going off in the distance they
head into the arcade and challenge Brody
and his friends to a fight but that's
when a huge Rumble erupts inside of the
arcade it's coming from outside and they
go to check it out seeing a huge fire in
the distance fighter jets fly past them
Boo's friend janichi notices that
they're F-15 Eagles but Brody wonders
why they are flying so low to the city
and why they are flying faster than
normal seeing the afterburners he gets
worried and thinks it is a sign that
their city is under attack everyone
rushes to a nearby rooftop to take a
closer look at what's going on but
that's when they see something
horrifying Jets fighting terrifying
monsters firing missiles and getting
absolutely slaughtered dozens of
civilians get eaten in plain sight it's
beautiful I didn't say that but the kids
can't make out who the enemy he is Bou
then feels a strange surge of energy
within his body and doesn't know what's
going on no one else notices though and
that's when this fles eating monster
appears behind them ready to kill okay
well it might seem like we are screwed I
would get out of this situation by
relying on social deductive reasoning
sensitive hearing and a little bit of
Nando's Chicken let me explain before
this monster showed up everyone clearly
heard the low Rumble in the arcade from
that fact alone it means that the
explosion was at least 15 km away
currently these kids are in fousa City
Japan an area known for its American Air
Force Base and primarily a residential
suburb that houses workers working in
Tokyo the point is there are no known
nuclear facilities or anything crazy
that could create such an explosion like
the one we just heard except the Air
Force Base but if that's the case then
it could mean three likely scenarios
either an accident happened at the Air
Force Base that caused the explosion
which is unlikely or some attack
happened to the Air Force Base or an
attack happened within the city of fousa
and this is what caused the air Force
Base to react to the threat and deploy
weapons of some kind to it this means
that due to deductive reasoning and the
close proximity to the threat already
there was absolutely no reason to go up
to the building just now instead they
should have just ran in the opposite
direction cuz that's the smarter plan
and figured out the full situation at a
later point from a safer distance they
wasted precious time risking their lives
which got them here if I was Boo here at
this point we got to deal with this
Nando looking mofo without killing it
well we're you know preb bessing as hell
however we do have options we're
surrounded by a group of our peers and
not just any peers we're around military
brats an average military brat due to
their well unique experiences growing up
in international military bases and that
means that these kids are packing with
useful abilities abilities and skills
that we could use now that we're clearly
in the apocalypse this means that I
would keep one or two of these military
brats since their skills well could come
in handy I would also keep janichi here
since he is a big old nerd about a whole
lot of stuff but I would would 100% push
Joe and maybe one or two of Brody's
friends straight into Mr Nando over here
because their Shields of meat will give
me time to escape during The Descent I
would also try to activate the fire
alarm in order to throw off the
monster's orientation the children run
for their lives and Boo's gang splits up
from Brody the monster shoots its lethal
tail at them but accidentally gets
electrocuted reaching the ground floor
another monster catches them from the
front and another from the back traps
them into a corner about to die a huge
energy blast blows through the arcade
killing every monster inside the kids
are shocked and don't know what the hell
just happened heading outside they
realize who their savior is this Turtle
monster and they can't believe their
eyes the biggest creature they've ever
seen standing in front of them and it
stares at them right in the face more
monsters begin attacking this giant
creature but boo and his friends witness
their savior's awesome power suddenly
Boo's gang notices more trouble nearby
forcing the kids to leave the area Brody
trips trying to get away and another
monster tries to come at them but gets
brutally crushed by their new monster
friend trapped around the destruction
the kids watch this OG kill the last of
the red monsters blinding this one and
slamming it into the floor but that's
when this Turtle monster gets hit by
dozens of American missiles forcing it
to do the impossible deploying its wings
and taking off into the sky feeling
connected to the monster in some
superhuman way boo tells his friends
that their savior's name is Garra
suddenly a helicopter lands near them
and this scientist comes out and
approaches the Kids introducing herself
as emo she says they want to ask them
questions about the monster that they
just saw because they've been tracking
them for a long time she tells them that
the monster that just tried to kill them
is named G and nothing is what it seems
taking the kids to their local military
base they meet Brody's hardass dad
General osbor and he pimp slaps Brody
and gets mad at him for missing football
practice earlier that day because heaven
forbid the world ends a man that enters
the room wearing a suit he introduces
himself as tazaki and tells the kid that
him and emo work for the Eustace
Foundation a powerful worldwide company
that specializes in De developing energy
resources for the world and he flexes on
them a little bit that they recently put
a human base on the moon they give the
kids the rundown of what's really going
on the UN ordered them to go up against
these monsters known as Kaiju but their
company accidentally found their first
Kaiju 10 years ago deep beneath the
ocean seabed in a cavern and it's been
perfectly preserved and is at least
100,000 years old but that's when emo
reveals something shocky they discovered
human remains inside of the monster's
stomach and have found other Caverns
around the world and that's when they
discovered the Kaiju known as guos
tazaki tells them that Kaiju Monsters
worldwide have started eating children
for some unknown reason and they also
don't know how the Turtle monster they
saw fits into the whole picture but they
think it's no coincidence that both of
these monsters fought near these kids
and they think they are somehow
connected they then hand the kids these
fancy communicators and tell them that
these will let the military keep track
of their location and Vital Signs until
they can stop these attacks around the
world because that's what secret
organizations do tazaki then says
something strange and warns them to
contact them they're ever in any danger
or if they feel something strange within
their bodies and with their help they'll
be able to save the entire world making
everyone except Joe excited as hell the
next day tazaki and emo rushed to meet
the general Osborne because something
horrifying has just happened the general
tells them that they spotted baby Kaiju
escaping the military base into the
sewers and have now just gotten reports
that full-sized adult Kaiju have started
attacking the city emo and tazaki are
shocked at the news but for a different
reason they confessed to the general
that they were keeping ancient Kaiju
eggs at the base to do experiments on
but up until just last night they were
completely fossilized not knowing how
these monsters came to life General
Osborne orders all of his men to head
out to hunt the Kaiju down meanwhile Boo
and his friends go to meet up with bro
because he has apparently some urgent
news and he tells them that earlier this
morning he overheard his General dad on
the phone saying that baby Kaiju had
escaped into the sewers and they were
only the size of puppies at the time and
good old Brody has the most brilliant
idea says that they should go hunt down
the baby Kaiju down before the military
does this way they can look like
badasses on their way to certain Doom
amazing fortunately Joe says this plan
is dumb as hell because it is but boo
tells him that the military did say they
needed their help and so wannabe
scientist jinichi agrees and then
everybody peer pressures Joe to join in
heading inside they follow monster
tracks into this huge tunnel and
everybody says that they can secure this
tunnel until the military gets there but
Joe gets worried for Boo and says that
being here is a huge mistake Brody tells
him to stop being a little and
then they get into an argument but
that's when they hear a huge Rumble and
realize that this rock right next to
them is actually a massive Kaiju
silenced by pure Terror they try to back
away slowly but their military
Communicator starts picking up radio
cheddar oh how typical making the Kaiju
notice and it attacks the military then
busts in and starts firing giving the
kids a chance to escape outside they run
into emo and tazaki and they tell the
kids that they track them down down
using their Communicator devices and
they need to get out of here now because
Garra is headed right for them a massive
explosion takes place inside the sewers
and everyone outside sees the massive
Kaiju erupt from the surface the
military quickly provides cover fire and
this group gets the hell out of there in
the car daki tells them what this
monster is cod named jiger he says they
discovered this Kaiju before G appeared
and they've been investigating its eggs
for the past year but he doesn't know
how they grew suddenly and why now a car
that crashes into them and disables
their ride getting out they see jiger in
the distance when all of a sudden
another energy blast blows through the
area and Gara appears it quickly tries
to stop jiger but gets stabbed by its
lethal tail injuring it Garra tries to
attack again but gets fired upon by
incoming fighter jets the kids watch
helplessly from the distance and boo is
horrified sensing that gamra is somehow
on their side he has an idea and tries
to convince Brody to save gamra through
his General dad tazaki thinks he's crazy
but Brody finally listens and calls his
dad reluctantly his pops listens and
just then jiger in the distance stabs
gamra a third time and knocks him down
vulnerable it gets ready to kill gamra
just as it gets stopped by fighter jets
boo realizes that they managed to do it
and Garra gets back up quickly hitting
up its claw and it forcefully picks up
and burns its body alive and then
it just takes off again into the sky
later Brody's dad reaches the group of
kids but slaps Brody in front of
everyone telling him to not be
irresponsible with his life ever again
he gets sad but Joe tries to cheer him
up and he quickly becomes friends with
the group and none of them have no idea
that something much more horrifying has
just escaped and is headed their way 100
Mil East in the South Pacific deep sea
the next day the foundation tells daki
and emo that they have collected and are
analyzing more flush samples and they
found more ailum a mysterious energy
that powers and amplifies energy from
all Kaiju because of this new
development they ordered these two to
escort the children into their
excavation site in yonaguni Island by
boat in order for the next phase of
their plan to start convincing all of
the children's parents even somehow
Brody's Dad they tell everybody that
these kids these kids will be needed to
save the world and they trick everybody
into letting them go and they all set
off by boat later emo gives the kids a
tour of the ship they find out it's
packing some serious heat she reveals to
them that they're also carrying an ailum
Crystal and are using it to try to find
different races of Kaiju present on
Earth tazaki buds in and tells Amigo
that he's got bad news a new kaijo has
just sunk a ship 250 km from the code
named Zyra the ship was carrying other
kids who encountered the guo Kaiju but
now they're all dead they discussed the
grave news with members from the
foundation and suspect their ship will
be the monster's next Target and that's
when tazaki freaks his boobs off and
goes to tell the captain to get them to
the yonaguni island as soon as possible
outside the kids over here on the
communication device about the recent
ship explosion and begin freaking out
JiJi then tries to calm them down with
some math he says that the attack
happened around 10,000 km away and if
the creature was traveling 100 knots
then it won't reach them for another 2
days and they should reach their
destination by tomorrow night everybody
lets out a s relief janichi then
suggests that all Kaiju May belong to
some sort of ancient civilization based
on what he's noticed but they all think
he's just being a nerd okay this plan
makes no sense and this could have been
obvious due to Common Sense let me
explain there's no possible way that
junichi can tell how fast a Kaiju would
travel how would he know for context the
fastest SE animal in the world is the
sail fish it's able to move as quick as
a cheetah but in water at 82 mph or
around 71 knots and I don't have to be a
scientist to assume that a giant monster
could probably travel way faster than oh
I don't know a sailfish probably way
more than 100 knots either way it makes
no sense why they're taking a boat in
the first place when it's noted that the
trip between where they left the air
base to yonaguni Island takes 2 Days by
boat which is around 2,000 km apart you
would think that with the world ending
and them needing to get a little bit of
a move on that they would have picked a
faster mode of transportation look it's
possible that they're taking a boat
since it's carrying a valuable ailum
crystal and maybe it's too fragile to
transport any other way but transporting
both the valuable crystal and the kids
which they apparently need to save the
world is stupid as hell especially when
they now know that another ship like
theirs carrying children similar to Boku
and crew just got taken down last night
but let's say even before this other
disaster happened traveling by boat
should have been the last option by
definition aaiu is characterized as a
force of nature if I was them I would
have gone to yonaguni Island Way Faster
by putting the kids on a flight from
Tokyo to okanawa Islands since we could
have gotten there in under 3 hours and
then we could have either taken a boat
from Okinawa to yonaguni which would
have taken 10 hours and 45 minutes this
would have been a better countermeasure
than relying on the Kaiju to not being
faster than a freaking sailfish
unbelievable later that night the alarm
blasts throughout the ship and everybody
receives the worst news of all the Zyra
Kaiju has caught up to them and is
coming at them with the equivalent speed
of a missile reaching them in 10 minutes
firing a kinetic energy missile the
captain quickly Dodges the monster's
lethal shot and they see on their radar
that the Kaiju has now gotten even
faster the ship launches another counter
missile at Zyra Landing it right near it
and it explodes in the face allowing the
captain enough time to whip out their
secret weapon launching their em
propulsion he says this ship flying at
unheard speeds and the Gang tries to
reach their Island as soon as possible
another siren sounds off and they see
that Zyra is still alive and is now
traveling faster than they've ever seen
one go wrapping itself in bubbles to
help minimize water resistance finally
out of options Captain says they need to
switch to plan B Taz zaki's eyes go wide
and he refuses to go along with the job
anymore he tries to retreat to the
helicopter and Boo's group follows him
confused used as hell nearing the bird
they finally see their impending doom
and Zyra incoming blasting out of the
water gamra finally shows up again out
of nowhere and protects them again
fighting this water demon emo quickly
guides them back into the ship for Plan
B traveling below deck they head into
this submarine and the captain reports
that the two Kaiju are now 1,000 km away
from them meaning now is their chance
detaching they drop deeper and deeper
into the ocean barely escaping the
ship's explosion above them meanwhile
gamra gets into a dog fight with Zyra
and quickly gets overpowered sending a
shock wave into the ocean and gets
picked up by their submarine reading on
the radar the gar is down and Zyra is
hot on their tail and that's when they
realize that they won't make it to the
island thinking fast they stop the
engines and hide out below these sea
rocks quickly firing a missile in the
distance and they see that zigra goes
right for it junichi then thinks that it
might be using echolocations just like
dolphins and the Shar from fighting
gamra has now messed up its sense of
direction and then he has a crazy idea
and he tells everyone that if if they
lure Zyra on land then maybe gamra might
have a chance and he finds out from this
one sailor that the submarine recorded
the signal gamra transmitted moments ago
using this they think they could
replicate the signal and disorient Zyra
enough to help gamra kill it the captain
thinks he's crazy but jichi says that
they can lure it to a nearby radio tower
that they can use to set off that signal
the captain then mentions that there
happens to be one of them nearby and
reluctantly he agrees to play ball the
captain tells these kids that they'll
have to drop the off on the island alone
since protecting the aurillium is their
top priority tazaki and emo reluctantly
then take the kids off the ship and it
crashes onto the islands and everyone
quickly makes a move to reach the radio
station okay this is madness we would
have been able to figure out Zyra Kaiju
weakness by looking at how wet he is and
where he originally grew up let me
explain while this is a solid plan
knowing the stakes at hand I would
prepared a better T-Bone combo of a
second plan at this point we know that
Zyra Kaiju is aquatic and nature and
since Kaiju were found within the
Earth's crust deep below I believe it
would be then safe to say that this
creature would have acted much like
other deepsea creatures out there
including similar weaknesses since they
also have been living down there in
order to survive in a harsh dark
environment most deep sea organisms have
evolved to possess a highly specialized
visual system which makes them sensitive
to small amounts of light found within
that environment this genetic trait
makes deep sea organisms vulnerable to
sunlight and to lights in general and
since we've now known about this deep
sea kaiju for 2 days from the moment it
was first cited which means that it
would have been possible for the
military to mobilize action plans
designed to exploit this very likely
possible weakness within the Zyra kaiju
for example the Sun or fire since it's
also safe to assume that the opposite of
water is fire because every water
creature would be susceptible to heat we
could have even notified the US military
base that just so happens to be closed
by their location realizing none of
their men are there to escort them they
haul ass by foot just as Zyra pops out
from the water in the distance and comes
right at them rushing in they work
together to quickly turn on the radio
emitting a piercing signal it hits Zyra
and it collapses and loses its sense of
direction for a split second and that's
when boo gets hit with the worst
headache and gamra blasts out from the
water taking terrifying hits it
overpowers zigra and blasts it with
radiation killing it and saving the kids
yet again and then heads back into the
ocean leaving everybody confused as to
what this giant creature's motives might
be and they extract another ailum
Crystal another ship then enters the
harbor and everybody gets news that they
will be continuing their horrifying
journey to yonaguni on this boat but a
little bit later tazaki and emiko then
noticed that more weird has started
to happen to their Kaiju samples they've
now started to regenerate noticing the
aurelan crystal nearby they wonder if
it's giving up some sort of radiation
that is healing the Flesh of any Kaiju
nearby and they're unaware that a new
Kaiju has just risen to the surface
right near them a few days later the
kids finally reach the yonaguni base the
most cuttingedge facility in the world
but Joe then starts getting impatient
and calls emo out he says they were
supposed to be back home days ago and
it's still unclear what the foundation
really wants with them Amo apologizes
and says that some new developments have
just happened and they're running out of
time if they want to save the world with
the kits that they need the other kids
try to calm Joe down and boo says that
gamra will protect them but Joe thinks
he's just being naive emo interrupts and
tells them that once they go through all
of their tests they will finally be able
to relax meanwhile inside tazaki calls
the foundation for some answers cuz
things are no longer making any sense he
asks them why certain children have
started to get attacked by Kaiju and
what's aureli got to do with Kaiju flesh
but the bosses tell him that he should
only be concerned with the company's
three priorities to find out how to
attack the Kaiju to figure out how they
can create the energy that sustains
their bodies and to make sure humanity
is protected from them and they warn him
that he knew about the risks and the
secrecy of the job when they hired him
meanwhile Boo and his friends go through
all sorts of strange tests and emo
assures them though that everything is
fine and that they're just looking for
abnormalities within their blood and Joe
starts getting agitated and asks emo why
aren't they telling them the full
picture boo tells Joe to stop always
whining and emo tries to change the
topic and decides to show them what's
hiding underneath their base and what
it's all really about heading below she
unveils the first Kaiju they ever
discovered code named veros over 100,000
years old they've never found any other
Kaiju fossil and she explains to them
that aureli is the life force behind all
Kaiju when it loses its energy the
molecular structure of its Flesh and
Bones decompose and accelerated rates
this in their view is the daddy of all
Kaiju different from the rest they've
ever fought tazaki then enters annoyed
as hell and he demands to speak to emo
in private forcing her to drop these
kids off at their rooms to chill Boku
and the three get Amazed by all the cool
stuff but Joe says that all of this is
off outside daki tells emo that he just
found out that another Kaiju has been
spotted where they fought the last one
and it's eaten all of zyra's body and is
now probably headed right for them he
wants to know why didn't the foundation
tell them this on the call Amo then
tries to calm him down but he tells her
that no this is his last straw he's
quitting his job and will leave when the
next transport helicopter arrives
shocking hemo makes her a little bit sad
well too bad for her because that was
his biggest mistake back inside of their
rooms Joe discovers that the front door
is now locked shocked he tries to tell
the group that he was right about this
place but boo says that he trusts Amo
and everything that they're trying to do
Joe tries to put his foot down but boo
angrily tells him that he should stop
treating him like his dead brother Joe
gets pissed off because his brother died
sad backstory but his not boor and
decides to leave the room by himself
jinichi joins him and says that there is
something else he wants to see the two
then escaped through the ventilation
shafts while Boo and Brody stay put but
their piece is cut short when a part of
the base detects a rumble underground
emo goes to check it out and she
discovers that a huge seismic wave has
just occurred beneath the seabed and
they don't know why nearby tazaki Waits
with his partner and finally spots his
helicopter coming to save him Landing
the water beneath them gets violent and
something huge shoots out from below
slicing the helicopter and the landing
pad and this strange creature launches
itself onto the base forcing everyone to
realize what they're up against Cod
named G on emo sees through the cameras
and tells everybody that they need to
seal off the cylinder and keep this
creature away from the virus Kaiju while
she tells everyone to evacuate and
radios to Zaki that he needs to take
command of the remaining troops because
they have no one else frustrated and
trapped to Zaki AG gree but quickly
remembers that ooh nobody's watching the
kids meanwhile boo stares death right
through his window and rushes to try and
call Joe and jichi but their device
isn't working and they're still trapped
in this room desperate these two who
also try and Escape through the
ventilation shafts back at fousa
military base General Osborne then gets
notified that yonaguni mining base where
his son is has been attacked by another
Kaiju meanwhile in the meantime Boo and
Brody somehow finally meet up with Joe
and jinichi just as Guan attacks their
building splitting these two up it
forces them to come face to face with
the Kaiju itself but that's when gamarra
suddenly appears oh so conveniently
again and knocks back gon the two will
duel it out making the kids realize that
boo was right Garra is protecting them
missing his buddy Joe uses this
opportunity to go find Boo the two
kaijus battle to the death but gamur
realizes that this monster is faster
than the rest and it manages to cut off
G's arm clean off causing boo to somehow
feel the pain as well Joe hears this and
locates him and the two make up and
everybody then tries to get to the
bottom floors heading inside of this
lift it suddenly breaks and sends them
crashing down to the basement giron
outside manages to stab gamra causing
him to collapse onto the floor but
that's what when something crazy happens
its body starts powering up and its
shells starts spinning at light speed
gaining air it flies at giron and tries
to attack it quickly pulling up a slick
move and slicing right up giron's
monster body killing it dead and winning
the next Kaiju Battle a few minutes
later the kids wake up inside of the
lift and realize they are now in the
basement where the virus Kaiju is being
held there they spot an aurillium
crystal in front of them and notice that
the case was destroyed on impact strange
and Boku touches it causing a hor ifying
visual to appear around them they
discover an ancient civilization known
as the foundation an organization that
tried to purify the World by creating
kaijus wanting only the chosen ones to
survive they sacrificed special children
in order to gain control of these
monsters but gamar stopped them and
saved the world suddenly the visual ends
and they see Emo's men coming right for
them meanwhile on the moon the
foundation board members sit and discuss
their evil plans to purify the world
from the safety of their moon base but
then they realized that the last few
food shipments that they were supposed
to receive from the orbit station has
never arrived and they worry if they're
second in command emo has betrayed them
but this one board member says that she
would never betray her people back on
Earth daki helps everyone rebuild the
base but comes across emo and she tells
them that they don't have time to save
people and must focus on the main
mission because that's the only thing
that matters tsaki thinks it's a little
sus and she's acting kind of evil and
they get word that the children have
been found she takes tazaki to go see
the kids now drugged up and helpless and
tazaki finally realizes the horrifying
truth he finds out that emo actually
wants to use these kids in order to
revive the horrifying virus Kaiju and
this Kaiju will wipe out most of
humanity she's actually really evil
tazaki questions her and says that the
mission was to protect the children but
she says she has no time for questions
and threatens to kill him but if he
helps her he'll be taken care of taking
this opportunity he says he will help
her be evil if he gets a cut of the
organization when they reach the the
moon she agrees and reveals to him that
feeding the children to virus will give
her the ability to control it she's
double crossing the foundation board too
shocking tazaki because this baddy is
playing both sides tazaki then leaves to
go help out her minions and get ready
the Revival process well emo gets word
that her men have stopped the last two
food shipments to the moon base soon all
the board members will become weak and
desperate and then she'll be able to
take over the moon base nearby tazaki
pulls his weight and runs into Dario and
he tells him that he surprised he's
joining them in their Super Evil Mission
but tazaki says he wants to fulfill his
dreams of going to the Moon Dario laughs
says that it's possible that Amo is
lying to him and has no plans to save
him when they escape to the orbit
station and then the moon since everyone
he sees in this room will also be left
to die when virus awakens he then gets
sent by emo to go check on the kids now
trapped in this room but there he
discovers from the kids that emo doesn't
just want to wipe out most of the world
she wants to destroy the entire planet
once virus eats the chosen child among
the sacrificed children it will lose
control and begin to Devour the entire
human race and tazaki finally realizes
that emo is on a mission to destroy the
entire world and tazaki tells them in
response to this information to shut
their mouths and get ready to die and
leaves them in this room back in the
Revival room emo puts their aurelian
Crystal near the virus Kaiju and they
watch as it regenerates the man says it
will come alive in one hour on the clock
she orders tazaki and Dario to carry and
drop old Kaiju flesh onto virus helping
it to generate faster Amo notices
takaki's discomfort and says that the
chosen Will Survive virus's Massacre she
tells him that years ago her ancestors
from the foundation were betrayed by
some of their own kind they created
gamra to stop them from purifying the
world the computers then noticed virus
regenerating way too fast and they now
say that it will wake up in 20 minutes
they try to drag the kids into their
sacrificial cage but they break free
last minute and try to escape needing
them alive for the process tazaki gets
sent after them but then him and Dario
actually to help them Escape revealing
to the kids that they were actually on
their side because well emo is nuts
virus then starts regenerating even
faster freaking emo out and she tries to
escape leaving behind two of her men in
the process heading out they realize
that tazaki and KRW have stolen their
escape vehicle and head to the control
tower to try and stop them inside of the
ship Dario gets ready to take off but
suddenly virus blasts outside of the
facility and sends his tentacles to stop
them barely managing to escape they
blast off last minute thinking they're
safe they take a quick break either but
that's when the ship gets blasted
instantly killing Dario and knocking
tazaki unconscious using its massive
energy beam virus tries to go after them
but gamarra blasts out of the ocean and
starts firing energy blasts coming in
with an attack virus quickly overpowers
gamarra and knocks him out now free it
begins controlling gravity and uses it
to fly right at boo hearing them it
suddenly sees gam alive and coming right
for it it tries to defend itself but
gamra quickly blocks its attacks and
slices right through the world's
greatest monster back in the space
shuttle the kid saved to Zaki and head
to one of the Escape pots but realized
it's stuck they need someone to stay
behind to unlock it from the inside Joe
then Mans up and gets out to unjam the
jam and says goodbye to boo and he dies
in a fiery death the space shuttle
quickly descends back to Earth and lands
on emo and her minion causing this whole
base to explode barely surviving emo
wobbles out but then runs into another
baby Kaiju and it rips her face off yes
serves her right Boo's crew then
realizes that their Rockets parachute
won't deploy and suddenly Garra catches
them and carries them safely down to
land there boo realizes his pet monster
is not breathing daki doesn't give two
shits and tries to leave but boo and
crew convince him to help him save gamra
in case the foundation tries to come
after them which is a very good
possibility he reluctantly agrees and
causes military contacts to try and save
their greatest defender back on the moon
members of the foundation see that G's
life signal is dead but eagerly wait for
their plan B to start and this one
member tells them not to worry because
another Kaiju is a lot and soon will
find the children and eat them
triggering the purification event back
on Earth tanki's military contacts tell
him everything they know about the
foundation and their evil plans to use
the Kaiju to destroy Humanity he tells
them that bringing gamra back to life is
their only hope of Defense under the
condition that gamra can be controlled
convinced the military rescues gamra and
recruit the world's greatest minds and
they try to figure out how to bring
gamra back to life tazaki shows them a
piece of ailum Crystal he stole and
gives it to the scientists but that's
when boo collapsed and has another
Vision seeing how the Ancients healed
gamra he tells them to put the aurelan
crystal near gamra triggering the other
kids memories of what they saw at the
mining base drawing it they tell the
scientists that Emo's men hung aurelion
right in front of G's out of shell as a
sound was then emitted the scientist
realize what they're trying to say and
then they get to work on saving g a few
hours later they finally managed to come
up with a plan putting the aurelian
crystal on top of G's head with a
currency cord attached turning it on
they see gamra beginning to heal but
it's too late suddenly an alarm goes off
and they get reports that an
unidentified object is headed straight
for them the military lcks and loads and
defends the beaches they spot their
final opponent firing at this monster
they quickly realize that this one is
different and it quickly destroys all
Navy ships and shoots energy lasers at
the beach destroying most of the human
defenses in minutes this tank commander
identifies a weakness and he orders his
surviving soldiers to aim for its throat
and head watching all of this a massive
headache suddenly hits Boo and this
monster charges up its most deadly laser
beam yet to destroying the rest of the
defense and leaving everybody helpless
approaching gamra boo suddenly has an
idea to slow it down okay we're so
screwed but if I was them I would have
saved the entire Human Race by
sacrificing millions of innocent men
women and children by utilizing the
advantages of a landlocked country let
me explain this G is way more badass
than the last one which means that they
should have been way more prepared
because of this the military should have
never listened to boo and instead should
have questioned his abilities through a
more rigorous scientific process because
even if he was the chosen one they never
even bothered to question what that
actually meant in analyzing his brain
waves and through psychological
examination they could have come up with
some sort of hypothesis behind how his
powers or his connection with gamra
Works they never even once bothered to
look into Boo's abilities to see if they
could have leveraged them even more
unlike the bad guys who did this from
the beginning if I was the military at
this point I would have began treating
these monsters individually and
personally G or Kaiju Monsters whatever
you want to call them look like they
descend from Lizard based on similar
traits its eyes also have vertical
pupils which like lizards are designed
to enhance the amount of light entering
the eye certain subspecies of animals
have slight differences however at the
end of the day these monsters are more
similar enough where it counts and they
fail to recognize any of their obvious
disadvantages saving gamra was smart
they should have started thinking less
with their heart and more with their
mind by transporting and fixing him up
with an a landlocked country within a
heavily crowded City this would have
forced the GU to Traverse far on land in
order to reach te us which he would have
been slow at and by forcing him to come
across millions of innocent villain this
means that gaos Kaiju think would have
been distracted and killing millions of
people before it reached gamra giving
our best shot and saving the world and
giving us precious time to recover and
get back on our feet because millions of
people dying in comparison to saving the
whole world is a worthy sacrifice boo
runs to try and get the thing's
attention luring is to the edge of this
cliff and he gets ready to kill him but
that's when gamra blasts out of his
holding and knocks it back boo realizes
that he isn't fully recovered and is
under powered he emits a massive energy
and makes the monster collapse about to
kill him the thing shoots a tentacle
straight into G's mouth feeding him some
unknown energy quickly draining gar of
his powers about to die it suddenly gets
hit by blasts from multiple ac130 planes
coming in from the sky led by General
Daddy to save his son knocking the thing
back a surviving Tanger then provides
cover fire from the distance giving G
enough time to get back up he rushes to
pull out his signature move and
transforms his shell into a spinning
attack def fighting all of the hits
coming at it and he kills the monster
the foundation watches for the moon and
smiles at the death saying it's now time
to switch to plan C they reveal that
this one was able to inject an RNA virus
into gamra minutes ago because of this
gamra will be forced to return to
original genetic configuration AKA
making it evil meanwhile back on Earth
Boku now tries to approach gamra but see
its eyes suddenly turn blood red and
everybody now worries he's now turned
evil tagi tells boo to stay back but he
says that gamra won't hurt them he calls
out to him and far as his little boy a
gamra because of this with the last bit
of his strength gurra manages to reverse
the evil code inside of him and turns
good thanks to Boo's love oh how cute he
then turns his attention towards the
moon base and fires a magnificent energy
blast straight into the foundation's
moon base instantly destroying all of
the board members but this surge imp
power causes gamra to use the last bit
of his life force and he kakes the
bucket leaving only Behind The Shining
aurillium Rock saddened by the loss of
their friend and giant monster the world
eventually goes back to normal and
everybody rescues the kids and they
spend the last days of summer together
they meet up with tazaki later and tells
them that the UN has started to
investigate the foundation and he'll be
keeping an eye on them they then go to
the military base to go check on a baby
gamra in his test tube they found it
where gamra died and they get ready to
take care of this Kaiju and make it
ready for the day when more monsters try
to attack the world but what do you guys
think about the video don't forget to
like subscribe and leave a thumbs up
down below and as always don't forget to
check out our how toe playlist